there's an islanding and housing system
also that's made from a single
species of reed and it's called the
altala islands
and the muddy houses and you can find
them in the southern wetlands of iraq
and this incredible waterborne community
and technology
is constructed by the madan people and
they
construct these floating islands by
fencing off
a section of living reeds
that are called the kasab and then upon
that living fence
they stack the dried reeds plus mud plus
dried breeze and mud until they create
this floating
platform and these mud hive houses
and these altila floating platforms
they've actually
seen these depicted in sumerian urak
imagery so that would estimate this type
of construction technology
at about six and a half thousand years
old
and the cassava breed is actually
integral not just to the construction of
these
islands and these beautiful
cathedral-like houses but it's also
integral to every single aspect
of life for the madan people but also it
is food for water buffalo
it is flour for humans as well as
creating this material for these
incredible technologies of the floating
islands
and of the arched houses that are
actually constructed in as little as
three days and this casabrad it is so
incredibly
versatile that it can be stacked
into creating these islands it can be
uh bundled to create these beautiful
columns
it can be woven to create floors and
walls and then it can even be twisted
so that it creates rope that then binds
the buildings
that they're constructing which are
actually made without nails or
wood or glass and these madon villages
they have been constructed
in the marsh and they stay afloat for
a generation so about 25 years